[Music]
foreign
is the future of app development it's
opening a whole new level of feature and
functionality possibilities to make your
apps more intuitive personalized and
effective at meeting your users needs
in this video we'll show you how app
sheet Google's no code app building
platform is using generative AI to power
new features that bring app building to
the world
app sheet is a platform that enables
anyone not just developers to rapidly
create data-driven apps for Google
workspace without code it can bring the
development lifecycle for business apps
from months to days or even hours which
means you can spend your time on high
impact work
these apps can be desktop mobile or chat
applications for use cases such as
inventory management event planning or
marketing campaigns
so what's new app sheet just released
new capabilities built with generative
AI that enable its users to go from an
idea to an app in minutes all using
natural language let's see what it looks
like in action
let's say you want to create an app that
helps track travel expenses you can
start by describing your process to
appsheet at a high level
app sheet engages with follow-up
questions to understand the needs of
your app once it has the information it
needs appsheet previews the tables for
your app and even offers sample data to
seed the app for testing app sheet goes
off to build the starter app and when
it's ready you can launch the app
directly try out the app and make your
own changes or iterations
[Music]
in fact you can continue using natural
language to describe the changes you'd
like an app sheet will help you make the
adjustments to your app
being able to build an app in this way
with no code through natural language
truly means anyone is now empowered to
create applications for their
organization and in very little time so
what makes this possible taking a look
at the components at a high level the
user engages with app sheet this
interaction relies on dialog flow and
generative AI through a custom trained
llm or large language model which
together Supply the information app
sheet needs in order to create the app
dialogflow quickly collects the
foundational pieces of information about
the user's business problem that
appsheet knows it will need so it can
build a starter app that will land as
close as possible to the user's ideal
solution
after collecting the pertinent
information with dialogflow app sheet
sends a request to the llm to help with
generating the data model and Views
needed for the app
once the llm responds with the correct
schema app sheet takes all of the
information collected and goes to work
to create a starter app in just a matter
of minutes
the delivered app includes the database
the app interface and any configurations
that were expressed through the
interaction for example notification
preferences
the user can then continue working with
appsheet to customize and iterate
further on the app both dialogflow and
the llm may be used by app sheet during
this interaction depending on the
complexity of the request
the use of dialogflow combined with the
llm amps up this capability of app sheet
reducing latency and creating a polished
application for the user to customize
and deploy
so how can you use both of these
Technologies for building features in
your own application
dialogflow is available to application
Developers for creating conversational
chat interfaces
after creating a dialogflow agent and
defining customized intents and entities
you can use the dialogflow API to
integrate the agent into your
application
for the llm you can build a model to
meet the specific needs of your
application using the generative AI
support in vertex AI where you can
discover foundational models provided by
Google cloud and then customize them by
creating and modifying prompts as needed
and fine-tuning the models with your own
data
[Music]
we hope these new capabilities of
appsheet inspire you in thinking about
how you might incorporate generative AI
into the evolution of your own
applications
from intelligent assistance to
personalization acceleration to
extensibility generative AI is fueling
big leaps in Innovation and Google cloud
is ready to help you take those steps
check out the links in the description
below for more information on app sheet
dialogflow and vertex AI
[Music]
thank you